okay babies it's a push single bevel oh
my god it has been a while I've been out
of a like buffet after buffet and I'm
just so glad to be back okay babies
anyway are playing this game called
salad face it's very misleading because
like I'm guessing this girl's Sally but
you can't see her face because the
[ __ ] title is covering it anyway I
guess we will find out what her face
looks like okay okay let's try this let
me know
I guess I'll move this let me see yeah
put this right here I can't go then okay
it was just like the last time only this
time it started in a hospital okay I
guess we'll find out Oh leash probably
shut this whole thing slide writing is
that me [ __ ] hideous hello lady hello
it's okay so everything gonna be okay
now come and say hello is that bad
that's how come and find me I kind of
rode what sounded like my dad okay
any [ __ ] light in this place I think
something's here but it's too doctor
[ __ ] say okay um yeah right yeah look
at that
what would they think change it's cool
it I think light responsive let's say
the [ __ ] key right here thank you
okay okay next that cloud thank you
and everybody it's my eye okay that is
use my cane I did use my kick
I wish it would tell me okay I guess
what good day there's a [ __ ] mess in
here I say wait what the [ __ ] have I
can't visit this place three that's a
three over here
okay and was not nice
how is there like a [ __ ] that order
yep they're not good okay so it's day Oh
j-dog just pick the first letter I could
say and anyone save me my [ __ ]
advantages are getting wet okay
nevermind pants place how about dogging
me as I got a key as I got boy I
borrowed her a lot Chetty it's how my
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] gotta say by
yourself all right I guess I will Oh
Diana fish our mother and wife that's
disgusting of the mother and a wife at
the same time they that's pretty gross
but alright gonna people want to date
their mom so I can I guess that
batteries not included
need some batteries I guess and I said
three oh [ __ ] a [ __ ] break yes I did
there's a hurry there I walk like this
uh-huh
sir dad you know my son I sounded down a
murder wait am i a boy or a girl
this is your fault alright guess I'll
take a look in here mm-hm alright how's
that huh are you okay you guys iced
Sally face
yeah Isaac like little said I woke up
yes interesting sure I am there's a
comeback yet dreams later for now you
can talk
tell me more about the body which one
the second one the one from the
apartment what then I just moved in and
had a word feeling with that place right
away it's an apartment that's why it's
[ __ ] that projects episode want us
strange neighbors ok let's see what's
going on here
um I need to know I just need them now
ok hey my boy you're crying I don't even
know this we new beginning we could
finally leave what happened in Jersey
behind it's a [ __ ] a Jersey oh why
don't you go explore the building and
make some friends while and finish
unpacking
alright if you say so you know like I
don't really leave just yet
Sal's room she was in dad's room
dad you in here Hello Kitty's head take
a break for him packing that's not a bad
idea we've been at it for a while now
maybe I'll take a break myself I miss
mom yeah me too bad I'm a tail school
startup make some new friends I guess so
anyway friends to be friends with you
what what do you think about this place
the nicer old house but we'll make the
best of things as long as we have each
other I think we can have a real home
here go say a letter trying to get in
too much trouble I can't get past him
you got a quarter on the ground behind
him no yeah good I get get ok nothing
I got yeah a female if he talks like I'm
my guy sikhism it must be nice relaxing
or like saying oh yeah boy thank ya I
don't mind if I down don't mind if I did
I guess my that cat that's right let's
go to my room
wait Oh Jason sales room what else is
here
what else is here bathroom right sleigh
bed
okay bathroom stuff
back off on the store night before and
and I guess I'll just go outside he
needs new batteries just building yeah I
guess I got side let's see here let's
say what's going on here is it too dark
you're all yes hello mister cop hello
why are you standing here I'm protecting
as little friction I Q from saying oh
they on to say that scram are you [ __ ]
I'm your fairy [ __ ] get mother what
is that look like I'm an offer to the
halassi better show me some damn respect
what happened that room police business
what was that wiseass nothing tonight
thoughts they would wear doubt Kent
that's some man so man now I'm time okay
I just leave now
these shoes are worse that me my boy
you're a girl I still don't know
elevator on the fourth floor right now
check out that fifth floor place being
renovated locked and this one's open
hello
now grandma that act up here hello sorry
alright shouldn't have come here I'm
sorry just trying to get to know my new
neighbors in a deck place this building
what things happen
are you sure okay [ __ ] if the meth
dealer not great right there that's a
[ __ ] is he a gerbil likewise you'd
piss him on that jet okay that to leave
what is this bathroom bathroom door is
locked
you know I get it but we all need to
lock it sometimes no one else is here
okay open that one still is that one to
unlock or is that dumb
yeah it's lock still being renovated
right
locked locked on the ground 501 okay I
check that the fifth floor the fourth
floor now let's check out the third
floor okay baby
okay at three who is but the [ __ ] is
that God's house hey Lenny that's it's
going on hey oh my
sorry just stabbed me a little you know
I know she kept woman
you got some fourth - yeah am i a guy or
a girl thought like some would have a no
chance to stop in and say hi yeah it's
just me my dad my name is Sal so it is a
boy named Sal hey it's Lisa take care of
the place keep things up and running
super need anything to it it has it to
ask you're quite welcome
um I think I guess I'll check out floor
- that one's um yeah is that Charlie
hello man that belt you want to
introduce myself
okay come on in well what the [ __ ] hello
and what Sal just came in what the hell
is your with your face Jim La Nina
attains a generation of self-expression
I was young once myself I get it just so
long it's not gang or anything yeah gang
are yeah no not nothing like that
wonderful I'm Charlie don't mess with my
stuff and we'll be okay you know how
much does a collect a Sam like many
things these things are like a family so
if you missed my collections you're
messing with my family's and yeah sorry
not a problem won't be giving you any
troubles got to here and that guy is
sweaty is that grease on his neck for
that yellow passing the complete set of
my glitter ponies and current
accomplishment is to have a full set you
can look all you want but don't even
think about touching it what's a glitter
pony oh my god ah ha ha oh yeah my god
Chuck have you never seen my glitter
pony's rainbow spectacular it's only the
greatest show ever produced it's got
drama action romance comedy everything
you could have won and the ponies out
that ponies don't even get
started lighting yeah I guess I missed
that one I'll look for it on TV yes you
will just might you won't regret it
guys actually a psychopath man I thought
my character is messed up Jesus he has
got some issues that rock out not canal
ins huh I hope cars of course and act
like 10 times like that house got on
there okay I get it
yeah did what a pattern man that's done
over hello young Santa present it up at
an apartment or in floral - how may I be
of service I didn't know I am I know all
that takes place within these well sorry
I'll be good to remember that can I come
in no heavens no I'm afraid that I'm
quite particular but my premise I'm sure
you understand
yeah I get back well weird guy now on
Tom yep hello sir
detective hello young man he just moved
in today Greg yes sir
already but your father seems you two
are out the state whenever that happened
last night I starts out that's good now
trying to get in the way for now camera
mister getting a serious crap it's a
murder I can't talk about that [ __ ] so
long [ __ ] yeah that's like that's like
okay I've been here been yeah that's
over here no one's home yep whoa yeah
what do you want and let her out for
trick-or-treating is it stupid for
nothing kids I do it again see you again
why they kid sister make my life
miserable Amy alone they did again
okay I had going on loop now all right
that was weird anyway let's go check out
the dad I guess it's actually got the TV
noise yeah someone's in the bathroom
that's why no that's someone who's in
the bathroom that's weird I think it's
raining outside [ __ ] now you check out
my TV see if the I can watch out of
weird stupid show no I kind of your cats
get gone
yeah let's get it here let's see what
this guy's up to
okay I just checked that like the whole
place I gotta go into psycho power and
see what the neighbors are there real
quick mmm-hmm and oh where can I get the
basement I know I got that crazy drug
den see it's been on the air again
it's going everytime next to the window
and they help a little bit explore
building batters like I'm not blocked
and I've gone through everything again
with a lock lock lock lock
it's probably gonna be a new interaction
with someone there let's go three what
floor I didn't get passes what for I
just push it she can't she's anything
okay
I've been fail three to shame you and
dad at this chrony first impression I
promise ly things are still to both
groups were on here for Miss Anderson
who's miss Anderson yeah best shut
actually don't work here livery to 24/7
can't seem take a nice place you betcha
what do either say what the building's
over 100 years old people are
complaining about one thing down there
but you had no complaints for me I'm one
of action cans what small stuff
I think we're funded you around here
downstairs in our apartment you should
introduce chilly
Larry he'll be in the basement tell him
I sent you down and then a key here take
one okay there's the key building
haunted no it's not stay on all right
let's go check out this basement then
what look at all these guys mess that
little boy right here very act get pizza
whoa I just want so creepy okay here we
go
yeah all right what the hell was that
yeah hello anybody there
hey is it did they cover the bathroom no
you're not you up there okay lay came
out hairy job yeah Larry
your mom said I should come in just
moved in I'd say what's he like well
weird guy nice mask
holy [ __ ] is that way it's a prosthetic
and I should say I mean I'm cool he's
too much worse by now it's gonna be like
it's City I like no facing on there what
happened I'd rather not talk about that
I can't change the subject limb Larry
and Livie down here with our mom I'm sad
my friends call me Sally face I just
moved to new with my dad I never knew
Jersey oh so it was a boy named Sal but
they call me face because they don't
really have any decent friends to be
honest stare call me Nana figure out the
name then the answers gonna use it
against me
okay do it aren't you Sonny pretty
strange I like yeah we're gonna get
along great
that's what your mom said so now that I
was best happen forthright what is it
the killer still in the building holy
[ __ ]
so I'm having are you high right now
it's scary [ __ ] you know who done it
it was definitely Charlie big creeper
from 204 he's wearing gloves I don't
think any prints or anything okay so
help Miss Anderson with a clogged toilet
I was just finishing when I heard him
burst in the yelling a lunatic I know
what you've done I would tell me
everything you stupid [ __ ] Church calm
down before she gave me two words out he
was cutting her throat wide open oh [ __ ]
he's just saw the whole thing for the
bathroom
Jenny's out of the cops hey shad talk to
Kabul listen to me without some kind of
evidence like my words enough hmm okay
like your shirt I talked about some band
what
[Music]
No
[Music]
okay can we hurry up a little bit
[Music]
okay
[Music]
Stratus in strange guy if you say Edison
TVs in 91 and will give you a number to
a mistake
[Music]
your x-rays it'll be okay
please start for another day
if I make a fake coffin distract long
enough we'd sneak it up all right
[Music]
call in a bank robbery
hashas we had to clear the copters for
us a few minutes to figure out Hill was
really got to be able to do that so we
can make those mints camera use your
walk dogs communicate during the whole
thing then I can give you a heads up to
once I know the cops are coming back it
would just switch the bank robber with
armed robbery at a gas station trip will
make it a little unbelievable all right
I guess you're right good Kyle Sally hit
take this head to your room and let me
know when you're ready press the Y
button to call me okay all right let's
do this
get that to you though okay
and again this passion the here now
freaking noise and it's good to get that
tea really quick just while we're here
hello young sir no resident no that is
an apartment from 402 how may I be of
service a descent a place didn't thank
you coming right up
okay yeah sorry okay tell four is in
that job I'm just looking at really
quick to there's two or four now I gone
crazy okay let's just go break into this
[ __ ] place
hey ray gotta get up to my room first
[ __ ] I can't remember let's do this wait
a call give me a second okay it's up I
heard a bunch of rustling up Church I
think it's good to go get two for three
let's do this browser let's do this
oh my god in there yeah perfect examine
this bunch of broken coffee table some
books or anything important looks like
junk to me look in Mandy's break to us
tell me about it
oh my god get glitter ponies these
little figurines look like one is
missing I can see a small clearing in
the blood and that's it I know how we
can get him get out of that company down
to the basement we got him bro we got
him cinesín shall I both o'clock to
those woods so as the nuts over those
thanks santa-san got the super rare one
of something she was telling me about it
that
I was fixing her toilet anyways I bet
you Charlotte couldn't resist taking it
in fact I wouldn't be surprised if
that's why he offered her in the first
place I did always the give me the
creeps just something unsettling about
them you know
this is crazy it's got definitely a call
we can't live in a building with us
murderer exactly that's why you're gonna
get into Charlie's room and see if you
can find that toy wait why do I do
ice not gonna for three challahs do fun
of me there's no wait let me in you use
me up stick snacks whatever um snacks
[ __ ] fatty all right no dad won't be
able to sleep tonight oh wise cool
you're the man Sally all right take this
bengay you can slip the toy in without
touching it what are you good to faint
ends before
Nach what you're a tubing okay there's
the bagging tell flora Joe for another
so cool huh okay how do I get this
little [ __ ]
so yeah and I basically never seen such
an awesome collection yep
so alright Tim home you could step back
take it all and again nice place you got
I'll check a heaven just me and my stuff
Caroline have all the company ever made
oh [ __ ] who hasn't hey that guy is
disgusting said tape
I want that help
wait what
that's so freakin fast okay was it 104
yeah bro okay perfect give me some ad
say okay let's go let's go just a person
come on say from Addison
oh okay you know what I'll do the
sleeping pills okay and we get this lit
best yeah what for - yeah make it this
very good safe house okay let's get this
[ __ ] already already already you fat
[ __ ]
what
oh they're gonna arrest me is that hey
he's down baby get the [ __ ] out of here
he's gonna go ballistic LA right now
he's over here right Larry
I got that toy baby all right mr. Smith
Cremona naked dude thanks manor-house
nervous there for a second but now I
need to just get that detective and I'll
be over let's get the [ __ ] out of here
where is that [ __ ] [ __ ] boy right
there
I think it's on the first floor hey
again mr. detective
hey so I've got evidence say hello to my
neighbors you know I trying to introduce
myself and they're showing me all this
and I know what had blood on it per
second be helpful so I grabbed it my
lunch bag well a little up detective and
Chen huh not bad kid I hold on to this
just remember next time I come before
the influence that I put yourself risk
you got it babe a good bat Shelly that
[ __ ] hard no I can like [ __ ] Lena
good work today so you can rest is and I
got him he's so disgusting he's so gross
no one was around so I looked at the
back of the bag oh my god so disgusting
that's a horrific sight for anyone to
say let alone a young child as you were
thinking about it
and 15 years old and I already he pretty
had witnessed Edgar some Santa must have
very traumatic for you and I guess so no
they just let in the evidence I finally
proved Charlie with and you ever finally
proved Charles to falsely accuse don't
shut after so much realized pant bars
how did that make you fail neck
convinced it wasn't him yes they've said
well Larry what about him feel like I
said that guy was my best friend all
through high school and after high
school bent over this I lost touch with
Larry after graduation I don't know
where he is now
seem to be very upset by mention of him
I just thought now what get asking the
same questions all the times doing I
think it was to help my [ __ ] I
understand your frustration sad do I
want to help you but you just seem to be
holding something back the chin hold
back I can't I can't help you unless you
comply answer do you understand what
come from [ __ ] yeah yeah well
fortunately times up for today put your
mask on [ __ ] alright alright it's about
Larry I'm sorry Sally you know strict
hour with the schedule plus keep that
for the next session next week will be
last mood for your trout's I hope you
let me help you alright yeah guy put
your face back on [ __ ] man disgusting I
don't think you're a murderer Sal yeah
you might be the only one
at what
and as episode - okay well anyway that's
that one um thanks for watching yawns
tenon if we played next one I don't know
who knows all right
ciarán